we are moments away from a very busy
hour of breaking news president trump
set to hold a news conference at the
white house
we'll have that for you live but first
tensions high over on capitol hill today
attorney general bill barr
clashing with house democrats repeatedly
over the response to violent protests in
some of america's cities
democrats saying barr and the trump
administration are playing politics by
sending federal agents to stop the
unrest
in places like portland the president
wants footage for his campaign ads
and you appear to be serving it up to
him as ordered
in most of these cities the protests had
begun to wind down
before you marched in and confronted the
protesters and the protesters
aren't mobs they are mothers and
veterans
and mayors we fought for a democracy for
the right to speak freely
and you are attempting to take that away
what's worse you're doing it for the
sole purpose
of furthering the president's political
agenda and generating footage for trump
campaign commercials
and barr firing back arguing it's his
responsibility to protect federal
property
down a federal court is that okay
is that okay now no the u.s marshals
have a duty to stop that and defend
the courthouse and that's what we are
doing in portland we are
at the courthouse defending the
courthouse we're not out looking for
trouble
and of course partisan politics were on
full display there were plenty of
moments where democrats just kept
talking over the attorney general take a
look
you know i gave instructions as to what
my time
yeah claiming i'm answering your
questions reclaiming my time
the effort there was mr barr i just
asked for
yes or no so let me just tell you a
quote i'm starting to lose my temper
we were not taking down public health
orders we were making narratives
what time is it we were calling
attention
will you restore my time because this
witness is speaking overnight
over time
okay glad we have dana back here and
let's go
to greg gutfeld greg what did you think
about today's hearings
well first of all after that fiat that
was the worst thing i've ever seen on tv
and i include morning joe after that
fiasco
we have to reclaim our time for america
could you have you ever heard of a more
infantile loser defense
in the hearing that you can ask a
question then cut the answer
off with i'm reclaiming my time it
creates a one-way street
in which you can actually accuse
somebody
of murder you can accuse them of treason
and then you deny them the opportunity
to defend themselves meanwhile this is a
party of compassion
i saw nothing but fascists these guys
are no wonder they think the mob
the mob in portland in seattle is not a
bad thing the mob is just their street
team
and by the way they keep using this
whole this
idiotic excuse you know the majority of
protesters are peaceful
bad things do not become exempt in small
amounts
the majority of americans aren't serial
killers
but you don't need a majority of serial
killers to create a crime wave so let's
just
lose this bait and switch when we send
the police in to deal with violent
violent criminals we're not going after
the peaceful it's stupid this was a
contest
between who can ask the dumbest question
and for their premise to hold they had
to deny the reality
of violence that 60 days of violence
three police officers permanently
blinded
and bill barr has to sit there like a
calm gorilla
swatting these stupid flies off his nose
calmly
because they're so stupid and i mean how
i got to ask
how could anybody in america put up with
this
if i was sitting where bar was i don't
know what i would do
they would have to pump me full of xanax
because either that or they would have
to put me in a cage
like silence of the lambs have something
stuffed in my mouth and hung upside down
because i would lose my mind i honestly
i've never seen anything more disgusting
on tv
i thought the kavanaugh hearing was an
injustice this is pretty damn close
all right we're gonna cost greg gutfeld
off the attorney general list
because he would never be able to cut it
and then if i damn dana why don't you
take the reins from here
yeah sorry about that i i will we'll
give you back your time
since i was frozen there katie one thing
that i noticed the democrats have been
asking bill barr
to come and testify for months and they
finally get this date
and he gets there um unfortunately
chairman nadler was in a car accident
this morning
the hearing started 45 minutes late
understandable
but even not only to the greg's point
did they not let him answer
they didn't even allow him to have a
break to get a bite to eat like he
was so calm during all of that
what happened today was really a
disgrace dana and the spokesperson for
doj
tweeted after it finally was over carrie
cupek and said i'm reclaiming this day
and i think anybody watching felt the
same exact way
the democrats made a clear choice today
they not only didn't condemn the
violence but they defended it there was
no condemnation of anything that was
going on when bill barr was asked do you
think that the courthouse the federal
courthouse in portland would still be
standing today
if federal law enforcement agents
weren't brought in for backup to defend
the property and the agents inside
and he said i don't think it would be
still standing he was also asked if
oh well maybe the mob wants to come up
to the capitol building
and decide that they're going to take
that over or attack that with fireworks
do you believe that
the democrats in the body would be
willing to defend
the capital and bill barr said you know
what this body i'm not exactly sure
and their behavior and continuation of
cutting him off and
not allowing him to answer any of the
questions about very serious
issues show that this is just an
extension of the impeachment trial in
terms of their behavior
and they can't move forward and while
they accuse bill barr
of being political they were all very
political today and trying to put the
administration
on trial again and you know attacking
every single aspect of what they're
doing without
allowing him to explain anything and he
is much smarter greg is right like this
was so
dumb it was really difficult to watch
all right and a hearing like this when
you have an election year and you have
tensions rising high you can almost bet
jesse that you could see
a direct line from the hearing questions
today probably from both sides to their
fundraising appeals
back home to their um campaign donors
but i i don't think biden is on the same
page as the rest of these folks
the former vice president took questions
today and we're going to talk about that
in the b block we took questions today
and he was asked about the violence and
the protests and what should happen
to those who are violent take a listen i
think we do
need to hold those who violate the law
accountable you should never let
what's done in a march for
equal rights overcome
what the reason for the march is and
that's what these folks are doing
and they should be arrested found
arrested and tried
all right jesse well that was too little
too late
and i think everybody fell asleep during
that answer
because it wasn't forceful enough and he
just slid that in there and then just
condemned donald trump for the rest of
it all you need to say if you're a
democrat is
could we not light fires to federal
buildings it's really not that hard to
do but for some reason
the democrats just can't bring
themselves to do that it's like
if donald trump is against
people setting fires to a federal
courthouse they all of a sudden have to
be
for it i just think it's terrible
politics this was not a hearing
this was a cancellation they just wanted
to cancel
bill barr they were not interested in
hearing or listening to anything he had
to say and then
because they know he's armed with facts
he's calm cool and collected
and they're just angry they're furious
they look unserious
they look unprofessional and they're
just screaming at him and it's just
kind of bad energy tied up from him
turning the tables with the russia hoax
and him defending donald trump
because donald trump love him or hate
him he's still acting within the
boundaries of executive power
and he is not the wingman of the
president as eric holder said he was of
barack obama
he's upholding the rule of law and
really that's the problem with the
democrats
they do not want the rule of law upheld
if it was up to them and you can just
see by their actions
they'd be okay with antifa burning down
courthouses they're okay with violent
protesters attacking police
because they won't condemn it because
when you showed the video at the top as
jim jordan did
of all the violence taking place in
portland against
a federal property they didn't even want
to discuss that it was like the first
time they'd ever seen it
and it's sad and i think if you're
watching this
and you're a democrat or you're antifa
you've felt like you've been given
license
to riot because they're not policing
their own they don't like police and the
and the irony of jerry nadler denying
someone else lunch
not cool not cool jerry
all right juan let's get your take on
how do you think today's hearing went
well again i thought that it was pretty
boring because i
again i thought that what was said was
you know kind of
foreseen everybody knew positions
beforehand i don't think there's much
arguing dana that the justice department
under bill barr has is extremely
extremely politicized it was in february
that a thousand former justice
department officials
called on him to resign over his
handling of the roger stone case
and then in may 2000 former justice
department officials called on him to
resign
over his handling of the michael flynn
case right
so what you get now is barr is doing
everything that jeff sessions nobody's
liberal
nobody's protester jeff sessions
would not do and here i'm talking about
things like getting rid of the
u.s attorney in manhattan who's looking
into rudy giuliani trump's confidant
i'm talking about assigning somebody
john durham
to look into the origins of the trump
probe under
okay barack obama as if there's some
crime there
i mean i think that what bill barr has
done and i think that's what you're
seeing today
is people saying you know mr barr you
have undermined public trust
in equal handed application of the law
in this country and we are a country of
laws and this is damaging
and i think that's the big message right
so lots of different people can watch a
hearing and have very different
takeaways from it uh